Thank you.
What we're good Oh, he's good.
Good, everybody.
Thanks.
I'm going to be here today to make sure that the Senate colleagues had an opportunity to do some additional negotiating, I guess.
So at this point, the survey of the House members here, that position is still unchanged.
So I'll ask the Senate if you have a change in your position.
We will accede to the House position.
Okay.
Then at this point, just so we understand what's next in line here, is when we adjourn the session I will meet with OLS inform them of our joint decision and then it's incumbent upon all seven of us to have a signature on those documents before the end of the day.
works okay great and i want to thank you for your patience okay committee members any comments this ends the uh conference on 1397 thank you all for being here.
That was pretty quick.
Thank you.